as the musician billy idol sinks its  nice day for wat wedding bandai namco  announced Nina Williams the Irish  assassin is the newest character in  tekken 7 and in the new trailer Nina's  dressed in a wedding gown named the  fatal bride hitting some major ass out  of Bryan Ferry Nina's revealed coincides  with evil 2016 the largest fighting game  tournament in the world announcement  that tekken 7 beta retribution will be  one of the main games feature at the  tournament besides nina bandai namco in  december announced that Akuma a street  fighter character will join the growing  roster and play a major role in the king  of the Iron Fist tournament what do you  think will join the Tekken roster share  your thoughts in the comments